we do not typically launch an indictment
against an individual and then
investigate we investigate and then
indict impeachment is indictment meaning
Kevin McCarthy has said there is a
preponderance of evidence of wrongdoing
we're going to begin an investigation to
determine whether or not this Rises to
the level of impeachment if it does we
will vote for impeachment inserting that
sentence into the into the article is a
lie there's a tremendous amount of
evidence cited by Kevin McCarthy and
Republicans reported by the New York
Times by Politico by The Wall Street
Journal and these crackpot and even CNN
and so it's these crackpot evil people
at NBC News at the AP and at CNN who are
trying to insert lies to shift the
political narrative there is no reason
for that sentence to be in this article
because you do not need evidence of a
crime for an inquiry you need a you need
probable cause